Do you know this person?
Actually, I do know who that is. That's Jalen Ramsey.
My question is do you guys look alike? I want to know what you think.
No, I disagree
- There's definitely some similarities.
- I have chin hair. I have low hair.
This is like three years ago
So you're just blind to it?
Nah, I don't see it
Who is this?
Jo-
Travis Kelce
But you almost said it was Jonas
He almost said Travis Kelce was Jonas
But this is uncanny
That is kinda weird
Are there any differences?
One probably speaks really good English, and one doesn't
You have to see this, too
Nah
No
First off, you thought that it was Jonas
No, I did not
- You thought it was Jonas and not Travis
- I know who that is. I looked at the background.
What do we think of this?
That is. That is.
That is
Good hair and bad hair
That's a good grade. That's a bad grade.
Danny
He needs something. Danny needs a little something there.
Miss Jessie's soft and curl
Twins
Listen, where the Danny picture? Where Danny picture at?
Put Danny up there
So now they all look alike
- alike
- Look at that. It's uncanny.
They all look alike. I'm sorry.
This is just like the last Jalen and Kyle photo I'll show. I just.
I'm just curious
Nah, not even close. No, seriously. Not even close.